three amazing health benefits of turkey
tail mushrooms turkey tail mushrooms are
multi-colored fungi that grow on tree
trunks and fallen tree logs number one
it boosts the immune system turkey tail
contains two important polysacro
peptides psk and PSP they boost our
immunity by improving the response of
immune cells like monocytes dendritic
cells and natural killer cells turkey
tail also contains a wide variety of
phenol and flavonoid antioxidants which
help to promote the immune system Health
by reducing inflammation and stimulating
the release of cytokines number two it
has anti-cancer properties several
studies have found that TSK in these
mushrooms inhibits a spread of certain
cancers like colon and stomach cancer
another compound found in these
mushrooms that has anti-cancer
properties is Coriolis verticular glucan
also known as CVG number three it
enhances gut health turkey tail contains
prebiotics which help to nourish The
Helpful bacteria in your gut like
lactobacillus and bifidobacterium
research studies have found that
consuming turkey tail can have a
similarly positive effect on the gut
microbiome as treatment with Prebiotic
supplements remember to stay curious and
stay healthy